but another time my father he's dead
I stink the number one bus from Jersey
City Bergen to the high school and we
were on the bus one morning kids and
there was a guy reading a paper and he
had a connector of drool from his lift
the Daily News and there was a puddle he
was on heroin they would go to Jersey
City in those days and get methadone so
they would take the bus up north with us
so I'm sitting there he's passed the
[ __ ] out and there's got to be just six
inches of power this guy's been passed
out for 20 minutes I point my ass at him
and I lift up my hips a little bit I
kept my [ __ ] just pointing that even
if it wasn't boiling at him he would
ricochet off the chair and go straight
into his mouth he's sitting there I let
a fart go out and my little buddy's like
what yeah yeah well [ __ ] giggling I
should beat the [ __ ] this is what this
is why I hate people this is why I hate
when I repo guy give me a second
[Music]